le rugby-club de plaisir a réussi à
faire tomber le leader invaincu ris
orangis à domicile pourtant ce choc
entre le premier et le deuxième de
fédérale 3 avait très mal débuté pour
les challengers yvelinois avec un 10 à 0
au bout de 13 minutes de jeu
très crispée d'enlever au début du match
on a eu du mal à rentrer dans le match
et on était quand même assez crispé au
départ et après mais effectivement ça
c'est un petit peu débloquer ensuite on
prend un essai un peu casquette qui bien
que nommé à dix points et un 10 0 après
ce premier quart d'heure difficile
plaisir set accroché a réussi à inscrire
deux essais avant la pause pour mener 15
à 10 à la mi-temps
[Applaudissements]
au retour des vestiaires les ivy loi
concède un deuxième essai une claque qui
a boosté les jaunes et bleus les joueurs
de jean me sont élever leur niveau de
jeu pour ajouter trois essayé d'emporter
32 à 17,5 de soulagement parce que c'est
une très belle équipe on a perdu deux
fois contrôler la dernière ils sont
devant au classement il fallait
absolument qu'on gagne ce match pour
pouvoir recoller et continue et
continuer la saison avec l'objectif
toujours 17 finir à la première place
objectif rempli à la mi-saison avec
cette victoire avec le bonus offensif
plaisir termine premier de la phase
aller avec 38 points une longueur devant
son adversaire du jour comme pas être
que satisfait de ce bilan
avec une seule défaite amo et voilà
qu'en après l'échec la seconde partie
sera pas évident non plus et on continue
à travailler pour obtenir une deux de
ses deux premières places plaisir peut
désormais savourer sa première place
pendant le long mois et demi de trêve
hivernale le club reprendra la
compétition le 15 janvier contre viry
châtillon